raul says do you guys think masculinity
and men respecting themselves as dying
oh of course there's no doubt about that
i mean you can even just look at it from
a scientific stance and see that
testosterone levels in men are way below
what they ever were before in in history
so there's tons of indicators that show
that men are just not what they are i
think a lot of it has to do with a lot
of the food that we eat and just how
feminism has creeped into the mainstream
like this and just like you said how
that was a win for feminism and it makes
men look bad and she's being the strong
one and then will looks bad it's
demasculating men or emasculating men
men aren't supposed to be strong anymore
men are supposed to be on the back
burner and the women are supposed to be
the ones who are supposed to lead now
yeah i think um
i agree with you will
i've kind of
indirectly
dove headfirst into this topic with the
show that i do sawzcast because we focus
more on dating relationships lifestyle
and like kind of how money factors into
all that
and i've had the guests on like rollo uh
rolo tomasi shout out to him shout out
to fresh and fit and we've kind of
covered this uh
toxic masculinity that's going on
obviously everything that's happening in
like the news with transgender and this
leah thomas william thomas is the 400th
best male swimmer now it's the number
one female swimmer
you know things that are happening with
disney so we've been kind of covering
this and bill maher hit it right on the
head i'm a big bill maher guy
um
he basically highlighted how every woman
is in love with this guy voldemort
zielinski these days
and how convenient it is when a man
needs to step up and be a freaking man
because you're about to get killed by
the invading herd of russians that are
coming your country you know and
everything that be you know to save your
tribe but how convenient to use that
masculinity at that point but how
inconvenient it is when it's just you
know normal daily life
and that's something that i think people
are grappling with and the women's
movement shout out to women you know the
you know they're getting better
pay gap everything like their career
women awesome
but let's not forget that that men still
need to be men is ultimately what it
comes down to men are doing much worse
in society than ever before in a lot of
ways too killing themselves they die at
work more they're more depressed
especially young men i mean it's
terrible for them they're doing a lot
worse than they've ever done before it's
because of this this this new education
system that tells you that if your boy
acts out in school they need to be
treated like a girl
boys should be taught to be like girls
being a girl is the right type of
behavior and so they teach boys that way
and then you suppress their creativity
you suppress their masculinity and you
get a generation of a
feminine men and
women who want to act like men it's like
they're flipping them both on their
heads which doesn't make for a good
society you can't have a society like
that by the way this leads me to the go
ahead oh no did you see like the number
one clip on the valuetainment short clip
channel
for the last couple days what was the
clip again tyler was uh repeating
history can't hear your audio uh yeah
we're repeating history civilizations
fail when men become less masculine yeah
so torsha shout out to torsha who was on
with rolo and i
she basically
explained
how
back in the was it old greece
and greek times
that they they studied history and when
the sculptures and the artwork started
changing
from masculine men you know you know
whatever you know posing or whatever it
was to like more like
doing like more feminine poses
that that is when
um that pose was a little too natural
yeah but that's when um history started
declining or the greek civilization
started declining when men stopped being
men
and i think that's just something that
our audience will appreciate is that
just be a man man up and uh it's
something that
i think we more men need to talk about
yeah i mean it's too much dionysius and
not enough apollo in terms of the the
greek and it happened the same in
ancient rome because you had this at the
end of ancient rome you had this very
decadent society where men were not
responsible for anything because it's
not just about you know wearing skirts
that makes you more feminine it's about
not being responsible being a man means
being a leader and so when you have men
that aren't leaders and live in some
decadent easy society where you never
have any hardships which we have in
america today you can watch porn uh
whenever you want to get off you can go
on tinder instead of going to a bar or
something to get a woman you can order
food you can have someone pick you up
you never have to struggle with with
much right and so when a man doesn't
have anything to struggle or anything to
overcome i mean i'm not sure if you guys
talk to many you know younger guys but
i'll talk to a lot of people who are my
age my friends and we'll be talking
about like world war ii or
some medieval like the the storming of
uh like 1066 battle of hastings or
something we're all just like we wish we
could go to some more like that you know
it's like men today crave something
greater that they don't have so crazy
having a higher purpose
what's the famous quote
uh hard times create strong men strong
uh men create good times good
uh good times great weak men weak men
create hard times and that's it's
cyclical right so we all have to do is
study history and kind of realize what
it is but he's right about that you know
you you you hear stories about alexander
and you know the privileges they had to
see who were the real you know
man's men to survive you knew what it
meant to be the survival defeaters and
if you didn't
you're going to get exposed period it's
just kind of what it was and today we
are recognizing victims more than we're
recognizing doers we're recognizing
complainers more than we're recognizing
the guys that are quiet and getting the
job done we're recognizing the loudmouth
that gets up there says this is not fair
versus the guy that says listen i get it
let me just go do my part and order my
respect in the streets we're recognizing
the wrong people
last night we had a a friend over okay a
baseball coach here and a dean of one of
the schools and when having a cigar
in the backyard is me him
mario great conversation uh with uh my
buddy joel and the conversation came
about
the team he's got the best player etc
etc and i said every great organization
if they have the wrong number one that
organization is screwed okay so for
example you give me a good family that's
got three four kids if the
best kid in that family is the one that
undermines parents all the time values
everything the other three are kind of
gonna be like dude you know i'm gonna
pick up some of the bad habits you give
me a great company with a great number
one they're gonna develop other great
number ones you give me a company with a
bad number one they're gonna duplicate
the habits of a number one so you have
to
position your number one the best today
whoever media points as a number one you
want to be that person forbes magazine
the other day announced the
international woman award goes to
hillary clinton that's their number one
you got all these options to make you
know so imagine an average young girl is
watching and saying oh wow she's the
international i want to want to be that
let me go read her wikipedia this is
what i got to do i'm going to be like
her when i grow up i'm sorry girl
watching better hide her emails yeah so
but the point being we have to be very
careful who we turn into hero i think
america has hero making machine wrong
today by a mile and they gotta fix it
asap and not apologize for it okay you
cannot apologize for it i read a quote
that they uh posted it on instagram
what's the guys in pj o'rourke is that
his name he's got the same last name as
you by the way
and he said the final one if you want to
put it up uh well you may not be able to
put it up because it's on instagram
poverty can't be eliminated by push by
punishing people who escape poverty one
more time quote by pj o'rourke poverty
cannot be eliminated
by punishing people who escaped
poverty right you cannot eliminate it
most people like all these rich people
they got their money from their parents
you know what percentage of people got
their money from their parents and
here's less than 10 yeah 80 of people
who are millionaires are
first-generation millionaires they had
to figure out a way to make that money
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]